welcome to this video playing chess kids
what flag is that Singapore ok chest
kids no play to this guy before yeah i'm
recording this video on relatively early
morning and one idea and was that might
get slightly different opponents yeah
because you have those with the time
zones and so on if you record at a
different time it might happen that you
get different different opposition him
not the same guys all the time and it
was quite successful the last couple of
the last couple of games i really didn't
get some those guys before you're
interesting at the same position in the
game earlier just a couple of like
yesterday or something recording date at
least so it should be released a couple
of days before this video and it should
be ok for black but somehow it wasn't
with non castles and stuff this disgaea
in the other game you really got a good
game i played a 6b five hoping for
compensation but it didn't really
materialize yeah one problem here for
why it is a little bit how do you
develop yeah if you don't cancel long i
mean it's not so easy Bishop d3 95 is a
little bit awkward with pressure against
c4 nitey to blunder c4 night h3 you gets
taken it's not so easy to develop so
you're somewhat drawn too long castles
and bishop 86 because while the other
the normal development is is just
failing somehow yeah this is another
move along along the slides um yeah he
might might injure me is intending
Bishop g5 area
okay I'm going here for c6 cannot really
tolerate this knight on d5 for long and
c6 is something that I like to do anyway
Bishop d3 really that c6 now looks
really decent young Knight f6 Queen f6c
for Hank sand beach wangs it looks kinda
critical for white already or am I
seeing ghosts cm what is what is he
doing now check now this is just good
for wider see far as hanging and I'm
threatening 93 queen bee too he's
totally underdeveloped so I'm already
quite troublesome this position for
white
is closing material here and it's
serious yeah like 93 Queen III queen bee
too there's g2 hanging out it's not just
a pawn or something that gets lost now
what position is warning exam part yeah
it's really it's really terrible this
position um yeah amazing how quickly
this went downhill the relatively best
light according to the comp is nighty to
it this is still mine is free I like
like this obviously a disastrous
position with night coming here and so
on yeah 11 issue is that I'm for some
reason people like here I mean this is
just not very good it's not very well
coordinated after that white should
probably play this or on Knight f3 to
cover deform here it's a case where
after this I'm winning a temple
basically on this Bishop because you
cannot allow me to take the dark squared
Bishop if it is taken the dark square
see it would be totally weak so white
has to retreat and this loses time
somehow if you compare this to a night
capturing on before the night can stay
on d4 so you're essentially giving away
some moves here and I think the next
problem was that yay around here you
really have to think as white how to get
your your pieces out and yeah maybe
maybe maybe a move like this is
interesting you are covering c4 so that
you can actually play nighty to 2f form
it's already a little bit awkward
because of your lack and development the
the problem for black is that the knight
on c6 it won this tempo but it is not
particularly well placed on c6 because
you want c6 pawn to c6 and d5 to open up
the center to exploit your leading
development but this is somewhat
hampered by the night being on see
success you cannot go see 6 and let's
take some arrows back so maybe b3 was an
idea and this is now already critical
see success i 95 is a move that I think
of any way here to prepare c6 and TSE
six will even come with the tempo and
p.m. awkward this is awkward look see
one seems to be best it gives black an
advantage says the combat zone just one
pawn in terms of evaluation and here
you're really busted young I mean you
cannot cannot retreat this is this is
hot so crazy now chapter here yahoo use
either it's not not too early look see
one for example i have the choice i can
now check and note that this hangs is
well you why can't play after Luke see
what I can also go d 5 which is also
very logical am blasting open the whole
the whole position yeah that's right
we're not survive this pretty issue
about it compass on minus three yeah why
definitely if you look at the opening I
mean here Bishop e3 is of course not bad
or anything but there is no big reason
not to play Knight c3 first because well
it has to go there anyway and if black
now go see five you have a pleasant
choice you can go here here or you can
play D 5 D 5 is maybe not the most
testing move here but also playable but
Knight f3 or 92 now would be normal just
to cover here and this is an entirely
different position here you can develop
very smoothly and don't run into a big
yeah that that you're falling so far
behind the development is white yeah
okay i hope you enjoyed this game thanks
for watching